[Музика]
мене звати Наталія, і настав час для нашого
уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся, що ви
всі щасливі та здорові, тому що ми знаємо,
що нам потрібно для цього виду спорту та хорошої
їжі, давайте поговоримо про спорт, але перш ніж я
я хотів би, щоб ви пройшли через усе
те, про що ми вже дізналися,
звичайно, ми знаємо різні назви видів
спорту, і ми знаємо, як їх використовувати під час
гри.  Мені подобається
це в цьому виді спорту і навіть
трохи поговоримо про свій вид спорту на досвіді,
звичайно, ми зробили кілька грамів з модальними дієсловами,
ви знаєте різницю між прислівниками
та прикметниками, і я сподіваюся, ви знаєте,
як бути кращим і найкращим, використовуючи
ступені порівняння  ми знаємо, хто
найшвидший бігун у світі, але ми також
знаємо, що повільний бігун може виграти гонку,
якщо він або вона продовжує тренуватися та наполегливо працювати,
також ми знаємо, що спорт може бути
небезпечним, і ми знаємо, що стріляти, а що
не слід робити  з цим і, звичайно, ви
мали  your home past давайте перевіримо це
ваше домашнє завдання полягало в тому, щоб завершити
речення про вас давайте подивимося на мій
варіант я люблю бігати як біг підтюпцем,
тому що після народження як ми використовуємо дієслово
із закінченням ing ok
я бігаю щоранку номер два я
хотів би спробувати  віндсерфінг одного дня я люблю
бути на вулиці у воді після того, як я хотів би, щоб
ми спробували добре я люблю бути на вулиці
після кохання ми використовуємо бути номером три я
хочу прийти в спортзал на потяг я хочу
прийти так, це правильно, я повинен одягнути
masks to enter and shop after masked
модальне дієслово, яке ми використовуємо put номер п'ять
я повинен займатися йогою щодня, щоб підтримувати
форму, добре після зйомки модель робота, яку ми використовуємо
do і останній я не можу керувати машиною
також модальне дієслово good, і це було
завдання створити свій власний вид спорту, і це може
бути віндсерфінг у тренажерному залі, тому, як
традиційний, у нас є перший тест,
виберіть правильне слово
я читаю речення з двома варіантами
ви даєте вам батька я даю вам трохи
часу, а потім ми порівнюємо з  мій варіант
добре номер на  e Я не піду або не приєднаюся до
класу карате твій батько мій варіант
так я хочу приєднатися до класу карате номер
два
Робін любить готувати або готувати ваш варіант
так правильно Робін любить готувати номер
три ми не можемо грати або грати в теніс
це  дощ твій варіант так
ми не можемо грати в теніс і останнє, що
ти не повинен їсти або їсти занадто багато
цукру твої батьки, ти не повинен їсти занадто
багато цукру, чудово,
так що зараз у нас є час рухатися, давайте
зробимо вправу, яку ти пам’ятай  правила, якщо
я скажу вид спорту, який ми використовуємо для гри,
ви плескаєте в долоні, коли я говорю
спорт, який ми використовуємо,
думайте, а коли я кажу, що вони їх спорт,
яким ми використовуємо, ви нахиляєтеся вліво і
вправо, добре, давайте кататися на лижах  так кататися на лижах
шахи грати в йогу і ліву лавку праворуч
Курата так зігнути ліву штани правий
скейтборд так кататися на скейтборді і
і м'яч так добре добре, тож давайте
подивимося, які рухи ми можемо зробити ми зробили
деякі згинання вліво вправо
ми імітуємо ми плескаємо що ще ми можемо
ми можемо розтягнути розтягнути означає  s stretch
channel Tessa band що ми зробили поворот ліворуч
поворот праворуч струс віджимання віджимання планки
це стояння в дошці я можу зробити це
тільки одну хвилину добре
вгору і вниз ліворуч право і стрибки,
якщо ви не знаєте, що таке стрибки мертвого
джека  це ваше завдання знайти це в Інтернеті,
що це означає стрибки,
щоб був рух, і ми могли зробити добре,
а тепер давайте синхронізувати, що змушує наше тіло
рухатися, давайте проведемо невеликий урок
біології англійською.
наше
тіло і захищаємо деякі
органи скелет і у нас є суглоби
суглоби це місце, де одна кістка
зустрічається з іншою кісткою добре,
як тут, з'єднуються добре м'язи, звичайно, у нас
є багато м'язів від обличчя
до їжі, м'язи з'єднані з
кістками і  коли вони стають довшими чи
коротшими, так, вони роблять мус для тіла, у
нас є лікоть, лікоть, це суглоб у нашій
руці, а у нас я, я – суглоб у нашій
нозі, тому ми маємо трохи біології тіла, і ми
можемо далі вгадати, що ми використовуємо лише 17
м'язи на нашому обличчі, коли ми посміхаємося
і використовуємо 43 м'язи на обличчі, коли ми
кидаємо посміхаючись і кидаючи, ви можете порівняти, наскільки легше посміхнутися, ніж нормально кинути, і які м'язи нам потрібні
для різних видів спорту, наприклад,
деяких видів спорту, таких як біг  або біг підтюпцем
використовуємо м'язи ніг деякі види спорту, як-от веслування,
веслування так і важка атлетика ми використовуємо
м'язи рук наші м'язи рук добре деякі
види спорту, як гімнастика або скелелазіння,
ми використовуємо м'язи ніг і права рук,
а також інші м'язи нашого тіла, тому що
ви можете тримати себе на  рок і
говорити по-англійськи вам потрібні м'язи
обличчя ваші м'язи обличчя добре, давайте використаємо наші м'язи обличчя,
щоб зробити скоромовку, будь ласка,
повторюйте за мною
повторюйте за мною великий чорний клоп
укусив великого чорного ведмедя, але великий чорний
ведмідь укусив велику чорну пряжку  а тепер
швидше великий чорний клоп вкусив великого чорного
ведмедя, але великий чорний ведмідь вкусив великого
чорного жука добре вправа далі
чому ти робиш злочин Віллі чому ти плачеш
чому Віллі чому насправді чому Віллі чому n  ой,
ти добре, а останній чорний кіт сидів
на килимку і біля товстого щура відмінно
добре, іди далі, але не тільки тіло потребує
тренування, але й ваш мозок також потребує
тренування, тому що це також дуже
важливий орган вашого тіла без
вашого мозку, ви можете бачити вас  чуєш,
ти думаєш, що не можеш говорити англійською, і
ось деякі види діяльності, які можуть допомогти
тобі тренувати свій мозок.
Вивчення англійської мови є номером один, коли ти
вивчаєш англійську, ти тренуєш свій мозок,
звичайно, коли розгадуєш кросворди,
це також допомагає читати книги  дуже
корисно грати в шахи та виконувати деякі
ігри на пам'ять, наприклад гру, як
ця кора головного мозку, а потім читати книги, також
дуже корисно грати в шахи та
ігри на пам'ять, за цим посиланням можна знайти набагато
цікавіші ігри на пам'ять,
кросворди та головоломки, щоб тренувати свій
мозок.  давайте далі, тож давайте зараз потренуємо
наш мозок, давайте розберемо кросворд
добре, я прочитав пояснення для вас, а
ви дайте мені слово номер один,
вони є conne  піддані кісткам, вони можуть стати
довшими або коротшими, щоб рухати
тіло що це так, м'язи
номер два, де зустрічаються кістки,
де вони зустрічаються, так,
суглоби номер три вони підтримують наше
тіло і захищають органи це так
кістки номер чотири їхні суглоби в наших
руках
щиколотки так  ця частина і номер
п'ять є суглоби в наших ногах коліна
відмінно попрацювали, і ви можете використовувати це посилання, щоб
скласти свій власний кросворд, зробіть це дуже
цікаво, добре, але тепер давайте подивимося, які
здібності нам потрібні для спортивних здібностей
швидкість сила витривалість баланс вага
подивіться на  їх швидкість, ви можете швидко бігати на ковзанах або
швидко писати на велосипеді, звичайно, ви можете,
вам потрібна швидкість для цього, тому що вам потрібно
дуже швидко рухатися своїм тілом, чи пам'ятаєте ви,
яка найшвидша людина в
світі, так, це вивіска, наступна вивіска,
чи добре ви знаєте рок  для лазіння вам потрібна
сила, тому що ви повинні мати
дуже сильні ноги і дуже сильні руки, щоб
лазити, і щоб тримати себе на ходу,
вам потрібна сила для цього добре, далі чи можете
ви встати на л  наприклад, щоб не
впасти, вам потрібен баланс для цього, звичайно,
коли ви катаєтесь на скейтборді,
танцюєте вуличні танці чи займаєтесь йогою, наприклад, вам потрібна
ця здатність балансу і вгадайте, що,
наприклад, фламенго може балансувати на одній
нозі, коли вони сплять, а остання
стоїть,
як ви думаєте  можна пробігти марафон
марафон марафон це непросто, тому що
вам потрібно довго задіяти свої м'язи,
а для цього потрібна витривалість
нормально, а тепер давайте подивимося, як ви
розумієте значення цього слова, я даю вам
речення, а ви виберете правильне
варіант бігунам і плавцям потрібен
баланс або швидкість, щоб виграти гонку так, швидкісним
гімнастам потрібна хороша витривалість або рівновага,
щоб стояти на одній нозі
так рівновага, коли ми піднімаємося на високі гори,
нам потрібна швидкість або витривалість, щоб допомогти нам так,
звичайно, витривалість хороша, а тепер я хочу
навчимо вас рахувати частоту пульсу,
що таке частота пульсу, частота пульсу показує нам,
як наше серце працює нормально, а тепер давайте
розглянемо ці інструкції, перш за все,
тримайте ліву руку лівою рукою
великий палець ліворуч ось так,
а потім покладіть два пальці трьох
пальців на зап'ясті трохи під
великим пальцем, злегка натисніть пальцями,
і ви відчуєте постійний удар, якщо
не відчуваєте його, просто рухайте пальцями,
поки не відчуєте  це ваше
серцебиття підрахуйте, скільки ударів
відбувається за 30 секунд, ви можете використовувати годинник
нормально, а число п'ять множить число
на 2, це число ударів вашого серця
за одну хвилину, добре,
тому частота пульсу може бути різною, тому що
кожна дитина  є унікальним, тому він може бути від
60 до 100 і
12-12-12 чайних ударів за одну хвилину,
тож середній пульс становить приблизно 90,
але пам’ятайте, що якщо ви щойно
виконали вправу, ваш пульс буде
швидшим, але тоді, коли  через деякий час пульс
знову сповільниться, тому він змінився
після тренування. Тепер ви можете порахувати
частоту пульсу до того, як ви почуєте хунка, і після
того, як ви будете Roo hunka, а потім порівняйте, наскільки
він змінився так,
розмістіть цю частину тексту
інструкцій у правильному порядку  я даю  e ви
одну хвилину для цього, а тепер вони зашифрували,
ви повинні розмістити його в правильному порядку
добре, одну хвилину Ready Steady Go
[Музика]
добре перевірте це в правильному порядку, це
має бути так,
добре, наступний завершите діалог  з
одним із цих трьох батьків я хочу
ціну яка буде відповідь удачі
вітаю або побачимось так
вітаю
далі що з тобою не так відповідь
я почуваюся добре я вивив щиколотку або
я не люблю біг підтюпцем звичайно я
вивихнув  моя щиколотка далі виберіть
правильний варіант Я думаю, що ми їмо забагато
шкідливої їжі, це настрій, у ва
є точка зору або удачі, ваш ва
іант, ви маєте право, ви хочете пі
и зі мною в спортзал ні, дякую, я н
маю  дійсно згоден
вітаю правильний варіант - ні, дякую,
на мій погляд плавання - чудовий вид спорту
я згоден з вами о, я все добре, тоді
ні, дякую і правильний варіант - я згоден
з вами, і в кінці нашого уроку я
хотів би запропонувати  ти якийсь смішний
струм у тренуванні  nt під час тренування
це період, коли ми не можемо ходити в
спортзал, тому ми можемо займатися деякими видами спорту,
тренуватися вдома, підбираючи речі
з підлоги, присідаючи вгору і вниз, ми
просто підбираємо речі з підлоги
і бризкаємо  візьміть і шприцніть це дуже
смішно, і ви приберете свій будинок наступне
прибирання столу дуже добре
для ваших м'язів рук для м'язів рук добре,
а останній прибирання пилу
, до речі, хороша вправа на розтяжку, тому
приберіть свій будинок і
тримайтеся  ти в хорошій формі, але моє
улюблене заняття в тренуванні - це танці, подивіться на
це танцювальне караоке перед
телевізором, добре, і як зазвичай ми закінчуємо наш
урок смішним і дивним видом спорту
, ви коли-небудь бачили підводний хокей, але
він існує, і тепер ваше домашнє завдання  ви
робите цей експеримент, але для цього вам
потрібно записати слова з гальма
є слово зі зашифрованими літерами,
ви повинні написати це слово, а потім
виконайте інструкції і не забудьте
дізнатися, що таке стрибки
Інтернет добре, а також номер завдання,
щоб скласти два речення, як
приклад, коли ми катаємося на скейтборді, ми
використовуємо м’язи ніг і рук, і нам потрібен хороший
баланс, щоб рухатися, тому це кінець
нашого уроку, будьте здорові, щасливі і
до побачення
[  Музика]
ти